We introduce apparent ridges
for non-photo realistic line
drawings.
They are view dependent
extensions of ridge and valley
lines.
Given an object,
a viewing screen,
and a projection from
the object to the screen,
we define view
dependent curvature
as the change in
normal of the object
as one moves a small
distance in the screen.
Note that this value
increases towards the contours
because it takes
foreshortening of the object
into consideration.
Here we see curvature and
view dependent curvature color
coded onto the object.
The warmer the color,
the higher the value.
On front facing
parts of the image,
the two values are similar.
When the object turns
away from the viewer,
the view dependent
curvature gets much larger.
Apparent ridges are the
extrema of this view
dependent curvature.
We compare apparent
ridges to other lines.
Apparent ridges are related
to ridges and valleys.
Where ridges and
valleys do well,
apparent ridges are
in similar locations.
Where ridge and valley lines
are too rigid and boxy,
apparent ridges modify them
to be closer to the contours.
While ridge and valley lines
are fixed to the surface,
apparent ridges slide
smoothly along the surface.
Apparent ridges are red.
Ridges and valleys
are purple and brown.
Apparent ridges are different
from suggestive contours.
Both produce pleasing
images, but we
find that apparent ridges are
more appealing in many cases.
They produce more natural
images for facial features,
and include lines in convex
regions where suggestive
contours cannot appear.
Line drawings look
better when they
are thresholded appropriately.
Here we compare successive
thresholding levels
for the three different
feature lines.